the knives are out in 2020 Democrat
presidential aspirants are already
shipping each other
meanwhile over at the Democrat press
office of CNN Chris Cuomo correctly
calls Don Lemon small and petty rumors
swirl that Donald Trump will ditch Mike
Pence as vice president a university in
Texas says that being respectful is now
racist and a new study shows just how
much illegal aliens love welfare
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to the 2020 race for the
Democrat nomination
is already on this has nothing to do
with Donald Trump they're all going
after each other I know that I told you
a few days ago that Advent is supposed
to be a penitential season we're not
supposed to immediately start
celebrating we can celebrate this this
is the best part of the presidential
cycle so we'll get to that in a second
but first let's talk about pro talis and
make a little money honey with over 1
million happy pain-free customers and a
97 percent success rate Pro talus
insoles have changed the footwear
industry they've created a new level of
expectation never seen before for
comfortable all day shoes they have an
unconditional 90 day love them or your
money back guarantee custom orthotics
they can run somewhere between four
eight hundred dollars depending on the
variables what's worst is that while
most people stand to benefit greatly
from correcting common unknown foot and
alignment issues most people are
completely unaware or they're quite
aware but they can't afford to access
proper alignment I love these guys they
are totally revolutionising the footwear
industry and it's so easy I just put in
the insoles and I've got back problems
I've just run in my family alignment
problems and you just feel better it
properly aligns your ankles and people
don't know this that hip back knee upper
body muscle tightness can stem from
improper alignment and that all begins
in the foot what makes Pro tell us
unique and different than anything else
is its engineered with the intent to
focus on the biomechanics of your body
they've got a hundred thousand positive
reviews right now today my listeners can
save twenty bucks per pair on any pro
talus insole that portalis calm when
entering a podcast twenty a checkout
that's one of the lowest prices of the
year exclusively for our listeners
shipping is free
they had 90 day money-back guarantee so
you have nothing to lose except the pain
Pro talus comm promo code podcast twenty
save $20 per pair on any pro talus
inside if you buy two or more pairs they
will be upgraded to free expedited
shipping really really good kit you can
get it in time for Christmas
you can get a little gift for you too
personally we've gotten a gift early for
Christmas I think Christmas has come a
little bit early because of the 2020
Democrat nomination race for president
we know who the
likely contenders are Elizabeth Warren
Kamala Harris Joe Biden Bernie Sanders
he'll be about 175 at that point people
are talking about kirsten gillibrand own
I think every single Democrat in America
thinks that he has a chance to become
president in 2020 and so the big mistake
that these guys are making and you I
knew that they were making it they've
been making it for six months is that
they are all attacking Donald Trump
they're all running right now as though
they're running against Donald Trump the
theory here is that all Democrats care
about right now is how much they hate
Trump that's the only motivating
unifying issue so whoever can take the
fight to Trump the hardest is going to
be the one that gets the nomination okay
I I see that theory the trouble is that
as they go after Trump they're exposing
themselves to other attacks that they're
Democrat opponents are gonna use to try
to knock them off before the nomination
is wrapped up the case in point of this
is Elizabeth Warren she's been in a
personal feud with Donald Trump for a
while now because Donald Trump calls her
Pocahontas she's the whitest lady in the
country she's less Native American than
the average white person in America and
she pretends to be Native American to
advance her professional career Donald
Trump makes fun of this calls her
Pocahontas and she says I'm gonna put
this issue to rest once and for all I'm
gonna prove that I'm Native American she
takes a DNA test and it shows that she's
only one 1,000th Native American one
1,024
so she got so warped by her hatred of
Trump and by trying to run against Trump
that she opened up this huge
vulnerability
she thought that only Trump would go
after her as a fake Native American
she's finding out that that isn't true
her Democrat competitors are now using
this to go after her the New York Times
today came out said quote the headline
Elizabeth Warren stands by DNA test but
around her worries abound so it goes
throughout she took the test and it was
originally well-received by her people
but then then the New York Times admits
quote nearly two months after mrs. MS
Warren released the test results and
drew hostile reactions from prominent
tribal leaders
the lingering cloud over her likely
presidential campaign has only darkened
conservatives have continued to ridicule
her more worrisome to supporters of MS
Warren's presidential ambitions she has
yet to allay criticism from grassroots
progressive groups liberal political
operatives and other potential 2020
allies who complain that she put too
much emphasis on the controversial field
of racial science and in doing so played
into mr. Trump's hands that's exactly
right
you'll rarely see that the New York
Times reports something exactly right
that is exactly what happened
Elizabeth Warren if she were smart you
would have just ignored the issue she
she fraudulently pretended to be Native
American for decades to advance her
career then she was exposed she would
stop talking about it if she were smart
what she is instead doing is doubling
down on her premise and Donald Trump's
premise that her heritage her ethnic
heritage is the essential fact of her
campaign she's buying the premise now
she said I'm a Native American that's
why I should be promoted in my
professional career Donald Trump pointed
out how absurd it was that she's not a
Native American
and she's doubling down instead of
saying I have all of this other stuff to
offer to the country what that other
stuff is I have no idea but instead of
saying that she's saying yes I agree
it's all about the race where are these
news reports coming from you'll remember
that was not how the news reported it
when she initially declared that she had
taken this DNA test the initial story
that came out right when she admitted
she said I'm one one thousand eight of
American Boston Globe runs quote Warren
reveals tests confirming ancestry and
then the sub-header DNA analysis
provides evidence of Native American
heritage for Senator who has faced
Trump's ridicule this is when they all
thought it was gonna work this is when
Warren thought it was gonna work it's
when her hack Pravda shop at the Boston
Globe thought it was gonna work they
tried to pretend that a test that showed
she might be one one thousand eight of
American was evidence of her ancestry
validated her claims and proved Donald
Trump wrong they've now realized how
absurd that is because of the other
people Kamala Harris Cory Booker a
kirsten gillibrand to Joe Biden who the
people running against her don't want to
go along with this absurd narrative
maybe Liz Warren could keep a straight
face
maybe her supporters could keep a
straight face maybe the Boston Globe
which is her personal Pravda could keep
a straight face but those other
Democrats aren't going to deal with it
so those other Democrats are gonna be
picking up on Donald Trump's line and
saying she's Pocahontas and she's a fake
and she's a fraud this was the obvious
one and her presidential hopes I think
are done I don't think there's any way
for her to come back from this there are
gonna be a lot of other candidates in
the race so the Democrats are gonna have
a lot of choices this isn't gonna be a
repeat of 2016 for the Democrats it's
gonna be more of a repeat of 2016 for
the Republicans on the Democrat side and
there was Camille Polya who's an
excellent feminist anti-feminist type
she's she's so far left she's right I
think she voted for Bernie Sanders for
president but she defended Donald Trump
in many ways and she said that Elizabeth
Warren does not appeal to anybody what
she appeals to our left-wing Ivy League
credentialed urbanites the coastal
people living in a couple of cities in
America and that's right that's the only
group of people that she appeals to the
reason that she's still considered a
viable entity is because those are
exactly the people who write all of the
news stories so they're the guys who are
working at the Boston Globe or wherever
even that seems to be cracking the even
more nefarious one looks like it's
coming from Kamala Harris
so Kamala Harris senator from California
former Attorney General of California
she has been an early lead I've said
that she's probably the scariest person
right now she's scariest in that we
don't know much about her she's clearly
pretty intelligent she checks off the
intersectional boxes of the left she
doesn't have the baggage that all of
these other people do she's creepy Joe
Biden Pocahontas Liz Warren all of the
rest of them so Spartacus Cory Booker so
that that's the fear just today just out
today there's a negative news story
about her it turns out that Larry
Wallace who worked for Kamala Harris as
Attorney General of California and was a
senior adviser to her in the
Senate may have sexually harassed an
employee of his or an underling of his
and this occurred during the transition
from the AG of California office to the
Senate and so California has has had to
pay out four hundred thousand dollars to
settle the lawsuit that's my tax money
anyone else who's listening in
California that's your tax money paying
that out and where it gets pretty dicey
for her is that they asked Kamala Harris
what about this major lawsuit almost
half a million dollars for one of your
senior adviser sexually harassing some
woman and the Harris office said they
had no awareness of it they had no idea
what was going on this is not believable
this is not believable all the guy has
worked with her in all of her major jobs
and the lawsuit occurred on her watch so
either she's a lying which obviously she
is or she's totally incompetent the
office is totally incompetent if they've
never heard heard of this but it's just
not possible so if the lawsuits being
handled by California what has happened
is she goes to the Senate she takes this
guy Larry Wallace with her he has since
left and the new Attorney General of
California Xavier Becerra is the one who
had to handle the settlement of this
lawsuit and so he settled the lawsuit
does anyone really believe that Becerra
didn't didn't talk to the the Harris
office it's not even possible because
Becerra would have had to talk to
Wallace about the lawsuit and Wallace
was a senior advisor on the Senate staff
at that time so just simply not
believable but what's really gonna hurt
her in this is not the lawsuit that she
had some employee who may be sexually
harassed somebody I mean I think that's
true of every single political office in
the entire country what's gonna hurt her
is that part of the settlement was that
this woman Danielle Hartley the employee
making the accusations is not allowed to
speak to the media is not allowed to
talk about her experience as part of the
settlement
okay that's fine she's getting half a
million dollars almost I guess she can
keep quiet for about whatever demeaning
comments the guy made to her or
harassing comments but Kamala Harris
positioned herself as the champion of
the
me too movement Kamala Harris was there
going after Brett Kavanaugh during all
of those hearings she believes Christine
Blasi Ford she opposes Brett Cavanaugh
all but painted red Cavanaugh to be as
some gang rapists and we need the truth
to be heard and they've got a Alyssa
Milano sitting in the rows we've need to
be heard women's March me too and then
you find out that one of her employees
the office settled this sexual
harassment lawsuit by shutting up the
women saying don't talk about it you
can't go to the media the major
mechanism of the me2 movement is the
media without the women going to the
media there is no such thing as a me-too
movement the whole point of the me2
movement was these women feared
professional reprisal they had been
backed into settlements where they
couldn't talk about anything they were
fear afraid of all of these sort of
things afraid for their careers and then
they go to Ronan Farrow at the New
Yorker and then there's a big expose and
enough of these expose days take down
the guys in question this one is gonna
require some answering I think Kamala
Harris will basically get over her poor
demeanor at those Cavanagh hearings I
don't think people are gonna remember
that really in 2020 they will remember
this because this is gonna dog her with
her own base doesn't matter you know if
if Kamala Harris could win the general
if she can't win the nomination and the
the big question is where did this story
come from I mean this is so in the weeds
who were supposed to care about Larry
Wallace the senior advisor for the
Senate and a lawsuit that was then paid
out by the California Secretary of State
or I'm sorry the California Attorney
General where is this coming from this
is not coming from reporters reporters
rarely do their jobs anymore this is not
coming from conservatives conservatives
don't care about her yet this is coming
from either Elizabeth Warren or Cory
Booker or Kirsten Gillibrand or sherrod
Brown or any of these people and you
don't know which ones it's coming from
people forget that in in 20 2008 this
Holt the whole birther controversy
whether Barack Obama was born in the
United States
that was pushed by Associates of the
Hillary Clinton campaign that wasn't
invented by Donald Trump that wasn't
invented by Fox News that was initially
pushed by the people who push these
things which are the Democrat opponents
or the people within your own party who
were trying to get the nomination to
then go to the general election this is
just a little taste
ooh we're just gonna get we're gonna get
so much more of this because all of the
names that I've just mentioned they're
all running Joe Biden is all but said
he's running obviously Booker and Kamala
Harris are basically already out on the
campaign trail but now we know Andrew
Gilliam who was is the failed socialist
candidate for Florida governor he just
was beaten out by Rhonda Santos we know
that he's eyeing a run he was asked
whether he's gonna run or not and all he
said was well the only thing I'm
planning now is to be at home with my
wife that's the only thing I'm planning
now and I'm gonna help out whoever the
Democrat nominee is he doesn't say he's
not going to be the Democrat nominee and
he says I'm not so looks like he's
trying to do it and Andrew Gilliam just
met with Barack Obama at Obama's office
so they're all trying to get the
blessing of Barack Obama there wasn't
just Gilliam who met with him another
failed Democrat 20:18 candidate Robert
Francis
Beto O'Rourke just met with Obama as
well CBS is SuperDuper excited about
this one here's CBS on the prospect of
candidate bado
Roarke lost the race to become the next
u.s. senator from Texas but his campaign
excited Democrats across the country and
some would like to see him run for the
presidential nomination in 2020 that
excitement around a potential O'Rourke
candidacy is complicating matters for
other potential candidates Politico
reports that key donors and strategists
are waiting to see if O'Rourke runs
before committing to any one candidate
oh they're so excited the drunk driving
hit-and-run cross-dressing loser
congressman oh he could be the nominee
they're so excited he's another one
there are a number of others as well
we'll get to them in a second but first
let me invite you into my boudoir
speaking of cross-dressing no no what
are we talking about I want to talk to
you about so today is all about
making your body feel better and purple
mattress truly makes me feel better I
you know I sleep at least 18 hours a day
and so I wake up I was on the road all
the last two weeks basically sleeping on
those awful beds I sleep on purple
mattress for the last couple nights I
feel so much better it is my favorite
mattress it is simply terrific it is it
is different it will feel different than
any other mattress that you've
experienced because this is using a
brand new material that was developed by
an actual rocket scientist it is not
like the memory foam that some of you
are used to it's not like box spring
innerspring mattress it is unique it's
both firm and soft at the same time I
know that sounds like it doesn't make
any sense it does just take my word for
it it is both of those things it is the
greatest mattress ever you'll feel
really supported you'll feel really
comfortable it's breathable it sleeps
really cool I just love this thing I'm
proselytizing for purple a purple
proselytizer
you will get a hundred at night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund
backed by ten year warranty free
shipping and returns you won't need any
of that you'll get free in-home setup
and old mattress removal you you will
not need to return it you will love it
I'm telling you you're gonna love purple
right now my listeners get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that is a very expensive a nice pillow
so do it that's in addition to the great
free gifts they're offering site ride if
you want that pillow text cough FAC OVF
efe - 47 47 47 the only way to get this
purple pillow is to text this free
purple pillow
kofi face COV fe fe - 47 47 47 COV fe fe
- 47 47 47 message and data rates may
apply they're so excited the mainstream
media about candidate beta so he's
meeting with him - they're all meeting
it is going to be chaos if you thought
if you thought that the 2016 Republican
presidential nomination was crazy and
wild and who we have Trump and oh we got
these and little Marco and he's making
penis jokes during national debates and
he's doing a Rickles routine in Florida
and though Ted Cruz's father is being
accused of killing JFK and oh this and I
mean there's so much and John Kasich is
being John Kasich I don't is eating like
a slob
I've been doing whatever okay if you
thought that was crazy Oh baby just wait
until 2020 christmas is coming early
this is these are the first little
pricks the first little knife jabs of
the 2020 race it is going to get ugly
really fast there are already so many
candidates don't count out Hillary did
you'd be crazy to count out Hillary
Hillary is is behaving as though she's
running unfortunately she's trying to
sell out these 20,000 seat auditoriums
for her tour with her husband and the
tickets are now selling for $6 a piece
they're cancelling dates it's not going
well that this floating of the 2020
Hillary race is not looking too good but
it is going to be a bloodbath and it's
going to be so much crazier than 2020
because you've still got the Trump you
still have the Trump factor there and
the Donald Trump has whipped these
Democrats into such a frenzy that
they're making really stupid mistakes
like the Liz Warren DNA test they're
they're not covering their bases like
Kamala Harris trying to cover up this
sexual harassment lawsuit in her office
they're really not playing smart when
you get angry you get mad and you get
stupid you start playing really stupid
politics we're gonna get a whole years
worth of stupid politics so stay tuned
and get excited but speaking of you know
talk about a perfect segue speaking of
stupid politics Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
has a lot to say on the climate I've
been getting a lot of hate mail for my
stance on Fox News and on this show
yesterday about the moral incoherence of
veganism and how leftist
environmentalism
is an inversion of the natural order
I'll just I'll just let Ocasio Cortes it
explained to you demonstrate to you that
moral incoherence it's not just possible
that we will create jobs and economic
activity by transitioning to renewable
energy but it's inevitable that we are
gonna create jobs it's inevitable that
we're gonna create industry and it's
inevitable that we can use the
transition to a hundred percent
renewable energy as the vehicle to truly
deliver and establish economic social
and racial justice in the United States
of America environmental
social and racial justice by making
gasoline more expensive environmental
zatt which ironically will
disproportionately hurt black people it
will disproportionately hurt black
people who are at the lower end of the
socio-economic ladder and which
disproportionately includes racial
minorities so that's gonna bring about
well how is that going to bring about
racial justice by not driving
gas-guzzling cars how is that gonna that
doesn't what they're using
environmentalism for is to replace all
other religious and moral systems this
is the virtue this is the evidence of
virtue what's funny is what she said
doesn't make any sense obviously if you
think about the words for two seconds
she hasn't said anything she hasn't
explained how making gas more expensive
is going to bring about all of this
justice
she hasn't explained how it's even gonna
help the environment we actually know it
won't help the environment there was a
that study out about the impacts of the
Paris climate Accord and said it
wouldn't reduce warming in any
significant way at all even over the
course of a century so they haven't even
made the argument that helping the
environment will help the environment
but certainly they haven't made the
environment the the argument that
helping the environment is going to
bring about racial and economic and
social equality when actually there's a
lot of evidence that will it will
exacerbate inequalities and injustice
'as but one thing that I have really
admired about Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
and I think a real key for her success
is that she says things with utter
confidence she says words that don't
mean anything with such confidence that
I think probably 98% of people just buy
it just believe her she could sit there
and say banana banana flim-flam phlegm
chimney dude up oranges bicycles
aeronautical engineers and she and she
would say it with that seriousness and
she'd can't she hit the table to
emphasize her point and most people who
kind of tune out politic they would just
get the impression of a serious person
making a serious point and she does that
the left does that this
proportionately and it's I think that is
a key to her success but the the the
moral significance with which they are
in viewing this environmental cause is
truly an inversion because you don't
hear them talking about people you would
think that the the power to the people
type socialist populist demagogues they
would celebrate that we have radically
dwindling black unemployment radically
dwindling Hispanic unemployment
virtually no unemployment in the country
we have more jobs than people to fill
that the people's checkbooks are
increasing their wealth is increasing
their real wages are increasing you
would think that this would be a good
thing and they would celebrate that they
don't care about the people they think
that the people are there to serve the
natural environment they are imbuing the
natural physical environment with divine
qualities they're trying to serve it as
an idol as a as a false and substitute
religion and that it is bizarre but that
that is what happens because when you
get rid of traditional religion it's not
that you now don't have religion
everybody's got to serve somebody nature
abhors a vacuum and that will be
replaced by something else like the
president left wing slate of nature
worship nature worship and by the way
apropos of nothing if you're sitting
there wondering how you can look like me
how you can look this snazzy these
holidays maybe wear a nice comfy little
sweater go over to Daley wire comm click
this store at the top of the page that
will take you to the daily wire Amazon
merch store there you will be dazzled by
our limited time Christmas and Hanukkah
offerings including the facts don't care
about your feelings hoodie the get lit
gang Ben Shapiro Hanukkah sweater that's
the one where his head is a menorah it's
pretty funny and the for wise men daily
wire ugly Christmas sweater that I'm
wearing you can also get the Shapiro
University I I can take a little credit
here I I helped out on some of the Latin
that is on that shirt it's one of my
favorites in the store so they have a
lot of stuff go to daily white icon
click the store at the top of the page
and fill your stockings of your
conservative friends and more
importantly of your leftist friends you
know share facts this holiday season
unreal politics not on Ocasio cortez
fantasy politics those are
rumors swirling around that President
Trump will replace Mike Pence as vice
president these rumors have been
swirling for a little while I basically
ignore them I don't take them very
seriously the reason that they're
getting more buzz now is you saw that
meeting with nikki Haley when she
announced she was gonna leave his UN
ambassador she got an oval office
meeting he talked about how great she
was how she could come back to any role
in the administration that she wants and
so now she's about to actually leave her
post by the end of the year as UN
Ambassador and she's been meeting
secretly with Donald Trump in in the
last days of her term as UN ambassador
what's raised a number of eyebrows is
that these meetings with the president
have not been on the public schedule so
what are they talking about what are
they talking about that they haven't
already talked about and why aren't
these meetings being made public Vanity
Fair is reporting this so again take it
with a grain of salt the argument for
nikki Haley replacing Mike Pence is one
it would be absolutely just delicious
if Republicans got the first female vice
president in there that would just be so
great not I mean who care I don't care
if it's a man or a woman exactly but it
would be great because the left would be
very angry about it that they didn't get
the opportunity to do it that I would
really enjoy that she's also pretty hard
charging she's obviously camera friendly
as it were and she is a an executive
type in the sense that many people think
she would make a viable presidential
candidate okay and now is she the most
conservative it doesn't seem like it is
she seems fine though whatever she's
been a good un ambassador and president
Trump shouldn't do it he should not
replace Mike Pence the argument for
replacing Mike Pence is that Mike Pence
well he may have added something in 2016
he doesn't add anything now they're not
worried about losing Indiana he doesn't
add evangelical Christians Trump already
has the evangelical Christians so he
doesn't add that do not replace Mike
Pence it is a very very bad idea to
replace Mike Pence Mike Pence has been
supremely loyal he has been maybe the
most loyal member of this administration
he is he's excellent he's really really
conservative he was a really effective
governor he was a really good con
he's just terrific he's one of my
favorite politicians in the country but
also the the benefit that president
Trump would get by replacing pence on
the ticket you know having this superhot
UN ambassador lady who's also smart and
you know does very well on the campaign
trail any benefit that you would get
would be decimated by the by the chaos
and the instability and the apparent of
playing from a position of losing of
ditching your vice president it just
doesn't look good it would irritate a
lot of conservatives it would irritate a
lot of Christian voters and it would it
would just make Donald Trump seem
desperate it would make him seem like he
thinks he's gonna lose like he's got to
change something or he's not going to
win reelection really bad idea I assume
it's nothing more than nonsense but if
it is more than nonsense don't do it
dude mr. president I know I usually have
to make these arguments on Fox and
Friends if I want President Trump to
hear them but if you're watching if
anybody in the White House is watching
do not do it okay
now speaking of new stations that I
never ever watch and that nobody watches
over on CNN Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon
are exposing themselves fortunately not
physically exposing themselves but Don
Lemon is being exposed by Chris Cuomo
for being frivolous for being petty for
being small for being me and here's the
exchange I don't think I would shake
hands with him I don't know I would just
nope couldn't do it I'm not that big a
person I would hope that I would be but
I don't I can't fake the funk as I say
I'm not saying the Obamas did that but
they're there they go let me show you I
want to show you something nobody says
what I would have done okay come here
come here done or done you're Petty and
small not Petty and small that's real
brother that's real and real petty issue
this is not I don't have to shake your
hand yeah that's true but again you keep
saying me me aye-aye there our former
president spoke two thoughts one this is
the first truthful thing that has been
uttered on CNN in a long time Don Lemon
is petty and small and he probably
wouldn't shake the hand of President
Trump that's that's true
but also just look at this this is CNN
this is facts first this is that apples
aren't bananas these are the serious
news guys
what is this bit what is that like what
stick were we just watching there it's
it's actually pretty entertaining TV but
what on earth is that's facts first
that's real journalism give me a break
Don Lemon is small and petty and weird
though there's no question about that
Don Lemon also yesterday I think made an
oral sex joke on the air totally
gratuitous ly here is John Dean he's the
bee's knees Oh Oh shoes that's okay I
think I'll be seeing you in a second
don't be so don't be a chicken head okay
I don't know what that means take them
off the screen for those who don't know
a chicken head is somebody who likes to
perform fellatio and a high frequency
that's what a chicken head is and by the
way the people who know the word chicken
head know what chicken head means the
the Venn diagram of people who know the
word and who know what it means is is
just a circle it's one circle so Don
Lemon said that he makes an oral sex
joke he immediately knows that people
like me are going to call him out for it
so then he says I don't know what that
means
yes yes you do you know what it means
and the way we know that this is true by
the way is that CNN has a long history
of making oral sex jokes here is other
super serious journalist Anderson Cooper
calling Republicans fellatio giving
deviance here is Republicans have got
away they still haven't found their
voice Anderson they're still there this
happens to a minority party I've just
lost a couple of bad elections but
they're searching for their voice it's
hard to talk on your teabagging David
well thanks very much it's hard to talk
when you're teabagging if you don't know
what that is Beata too good lucky you
don't google it but that's the gemenese
making a very graphic very graphic sex
joke on the air so this is what CNN does
I'm just glad that they're admitting
that they're small and they're Petty and
they're mostly meaningless and they're
there they do not rise to any standards
of dignity because certainly they do not
we've got a whole lot more to get to but
I guess we're not going through too bad
we'll get to that next week we've got
mailbag to get to so if you're on daily
wire.com thank you very much
you keep qoph fa in my cup you keep the
lights on if you're not go to daily
wire.com it's ten bucks a month $100 for
an annual membership you get me at the
end reclaim and show you at the Ben
Shapiro show you test questions in the
mailbag you get to ask questions in the
conversation you get to ask questions in
the backstage you get so much stuff but
none of that matters this is what
matters this is what matters in
Elizabeth Warren getting called out by
the New York Times Kamala Harris having
to answer from me to sexual harassment
scandal oh it's just I'm just getting
the little aperitif of that the aperitif
of leftist tears we're going to get the
whole cocktail pretty soon in as the
2020 race moves on make sure you have
your leftist here's tumbler for it come
on right back we'll be right back with
the mailbag
I'm gonna burn through these questions
today from Zachary Magic Mike you so
often kindly invite us into your boudoir
so I'd like to invite you into mine okay
my fiance and I are to be married one
month from today we have strictly
followed the Church's teachings on
premarital relations what do I need to
know about the marital embrace before
our bodies become one in the sacrament
love the show Zachary think about
baseball think about that you've got the
you've got a runner on second you got a
batter at the plate
alright the batter hits a it's a line
drive goes right up between the third
baseman and the shortstop the run around
second is going around he's okay you got
the guy he's rounding first the left
fielder fields the ball he throws at
shortstops that cutoff they're trying to
make a play at the plate because the
guys rounding third he goes he's safe
he's safe and the batter goes in with a
stand-up double at this point if you
have made it this far congratulations I
hope you've enjoyed your first
experience of this blessed Union next
time try to get through an inning maybe
you've conceived a child I don't know
that's my that's the only advice that
I'm willing to give on this program I
wish you the many blessings in your
marriage and the rest of your lives
together from Margo dear Pope Co FFA did
you watch Ben's recent Sunday special
with Pastor MacArthur how would you
respond to MacArthur's erroneous claims
regarding the Catholic Church in the
Dark Ages why do some Protestants seem
to have such a negative perspective
toward Catholicism is there any hope of
unity among Christians God bless and
happy Advent yes I did listen to that I
felt there was much of it that was
worthwhile and on many topics John
MacArthur is quite educated and makes
interesting and good points on the topic
of the years zero to 1500 he made some
mistakes some things that were clearly
not true that were demonstrably wrong he
says in the I encourage everybody to go
listen to it's a really good
conversation he says that the church was
good for the first few hundred years but
then around the time of Constantine it
got really bad and the West was
thrown into dark ages for a thousand
years almost until coincidentally the
Protestant revolution and this is just
not true the the the so-called Dark Ages
never existed if if pastor macarthur
were right in that claim then I guess
Thomas Aquinas never existed if he were
right in that claim I guess Dante
Alighieri never existed in the in his
comments he says that people didn't have
a personal relationship with God for for
a thousand years I think Dante would beg
to differ I think the countless saints
of the church during that period would
beg to differ he says that until the
time of Constantine there was no infant
baptism that that isn't true
Peter calls for the baptism of children
or at least permits it in Acts he says
for the promise is to you and to your
children that all are to be welcomed
that all are to be welcomed into Christ
every one of you this doesn't exclude
children we we know Christ touches even
infants in Luke we know that Paul st.
Paul says the baptism has replaced
circumcision and obviously circumcision
occurs I think eight days after birth
something like that obviously that
occurs on infants origin writing long
before the third or fourth century
writing Origen was born in the second
century in the 100's says that infant
baptism is traditional Irenaeus says it
refers to infant baptism as traditional
in the second century so so that claim
isn't isn't quite right as for he talks
about how the church would not allow
anyone to read the Bible in any other
language that isn't true the reason why
that Bibles were not commonly held in
households is because the printing press
didn't exist yet Bibles were
extraordinarily expensive the Bible was
under lock and key because the pilot was
very very valuable once the printing
press came around that was just fine
before the Luther German translation of
the Bible there were 18 other German
translations of the Bible so you're
right there was a lot of commentary that
came on Twitter I received a lot of it
saying that MacArthur was was totally
wrong in his in his conversation and I
think that takes it too far
he his comments about the so-called Dark
Ages are not true but there's so much
else in that conversation that is so
worthwhile and interesting to get his
perspective on that I I highly encourage
you not to be deterred by that and to go
listen because he's got a lot of
interesting things to say and I think
the back and forth between him and Ben
was really really good from coral hi
Michael assuming you and little ol ELISA
end up having kids would you want them
to go to your alma mater for
undergraduate where they can get plan B
from a vending machine apparently or
would you prefer at 17 or 18 years old
that they not be thrown into an
environment away from home that's
hostile to judeo-christian values Thanks
this is a really tough question
I've been around I spoke at Franciscan
University of Steubenville which is very
Catholic very very conservative at what
I was so impressed by those students
obviously there's Hillsdale is a great
conservative leaning College Thomas
Aquinas College out here there are a
handful of them so where do you want
them to go do you want them to go to a
place where they probably would get a
better education or a fuller education
or a more classical education or a less
wacky education or do you want them to
go to the place with the name brand Yale
Harvard Princeton where they can get a
job on Wall Street and make a zillion
dollars or get into med school or
something like that it depends on the
kid I think I benefitted greatly from
being in a place where I was surrounded
by left-wingers you can make of a Yale
education whatever you want I could have
made a better use of it certainly I
could have taken a more rigorous classes
in some regard and my senior year I took
a class called the physics of dance
because I had to fulfill a science
requirement so you know you can go to
make of it what you will
what I found was being around all those
left wingers made me really think
through my views made me much stronger
in my views I went into Yale and basis
it basically an atheist and I came out
of it open to theism and a couple years
later I was a professing Christian so I
think it really depends on the kid if I
think the kid can benefit from and the
kid is a little contrarian and the kid
could benefit from being around all
those bullets I'd probably send him
there if if he wants to become a
seminarian or
or something like that then probably he
should go to to a more conservative
place from Jeremy where did you get your
smoking jacket I got it from my
godmother for Christmas it's from Paul
Stewart and they don't make it anymore
because apparently nobody buys smoking
jackets apparently the only customers
are me and 19th century English dandies
so you can't even buy the jacket anymore
it's too bad if you can find a smoking
jacket they're a great investment they
really do work they actually keep the
smoke off of your other clothing from
Darrin does the church offer any insight
as to why Jesus arrived on earth during
the specific time when he did
thanks love the show Darrin it's a very
good question the god-king lowercase G
lowercase K Jeremy boring made this
great point the other day on backstage
which are which is the bizarre
similarities between Christ who arrives
the Prince of Peace arrives signaled by
a star he is the son of God who utters
in an era of peace on peace for man and
you've got at the same time Caesar
Augustus Octavian ascending to the
throne in Rome when Julius Caesar died
there was a comet that they saw going by
and they took this to mean that Caesar
was in in a sense divine and so the so
Caesar Augustus his adopted son was
called a filius divi son of the Divine
Christ is phileus day son of God and
Octavian Caesar Augustus
uh sure Zin the PAC's Romana though the
period of peace on earth those
similarities are really beautiful the
Christian view of the world is a
semiotic view it appreciates the
symbolism throughout the world that
symbolism is really hard to deny and
there's that great Alexander Pope line
all nature is but art unknown to the
whole chance direction which thou canst
not see from Noah hi Michael he who
smells of potpourri ah all right it's
gonna week I was curious about the
inverted cross and other cross variants
having listened to metal music for some
time I'm familiar with its use as a
purportedly satanic symbol but was
recently inspired to look into its
meaning
Christianity could you elaborate on the
symbol and meaning or the history and
meaning of this symbol yes a very
misunderstood symbol it's an upside-down
cross so it's the it's called the
Petrine cross and it's the cross of st.
Peter
because when Christ tells Peter in the
Bible you are going to stretch out your
arms you're going to be crucified and
you're going to think it's in the Gospel
of John and at this point Peter would
have already been crucified and you are
going to go down the road and you're
going to follow me in my crucifixion and
when st. Peter was crucified and this is
attested to by a number of ancient
sources he was to be crucified upside
down because he didn't feel that he was
worthy of being crucified in the same
manner as the master she was crucified
upside down and that is why some people
wear the Petri and cross the upside-down
cross this is not the same as an
upside-down crucifix if you were to have
the crucifix which is the cross with
Christ's body on it and to wear that
upside down that would be a satanic
symbol that's trying to invert the cross
but the cross itself upside down is a
symbol of st. Peter and st. Peters
humility and devotion now as with
symbols it depends how you're using them
if somebody is using the upside-down
cross as a satanic symbol then that is
what that symbol is going to connote but
it has a long history in Christianity
and in good faith should be embraced
from Zachary to the best podcast host
I've been listening to your podcast for
quite some time now and the Thursday
shows are always my favorite because of
the mailbag now I'm sure you get tons of
mailbag questions how do you choose
which ones you respond to I would love
to know how you pick them sincerely the
guy who thinks you are much better than
been the way that I picked them is I
look for people who sign their emails
the guy who thinks your show is better
than Ben's and then that's the question
that I use that's the answer from
Katherine dear Michael do you have any
recommendations for Advent readings or
resources for someone who is new to the
traditional observance of Advent thank
you very much yes the book that I read
last year is the book that you should
all read for Advent it's incredible it's
by Pope emeritus Benedict the 16th and
it's I think it's Jesus the infancy
narrative I think that's what it's
called he has a
on Jesus and it's the first one I guess
I think it was actually written last but
it's sequentially it's the first one
which is about the Nativity and the
infancy of Christ it's a very short book
it's eminently readable it is so
profoundly moving that is what everybody
should be reading for Advent that was
recommended to me as Advent reading by
Andrew Klavan and that's a man who has
written books with words so you know
that you can trust the recommendation
from David mr. Noles I feel like you've
answered this question previously well
then why are you asking me dude I'll go
on
but what translation of the Bible would
you suggest a new readers start with
I've been to church plenty of times I've
watched Jordan Peterson's lectures on
the Bible multiple times but it struck
me that I haven't actually sat and read
it front to back
thanks love the show DJ I recommend the
Revised Standard Version the Catholic
edition specifically not the regular RSV
but the Catholic edition that's
important or the English standard
version the ESV those are the KJV is the
most beautiful the King James Version
but if you want one that's a little more
modern and readable the RSV C II or the
ESV those are the two best from rosemary
I'm a female evangelical dating a male
Catholic what do I need to know were
both conservatives that love Jesus you
need to watch his his wrists when he's
pouring the wine the Conservatives I
noticed more than the evangelicals they
got a free liberal pour you know then
when they're out on dates you got to
watch out for that that's my uh it's my
only advice take it from someone who
knows take it from an expert all right
that's all that's all I've got enjoy
your date's you'll have a you'll have a
wonderful life together right hook
that's our show come back that's that's
all for the weekend so make sure you
binge another Kingdom because that
another Kingdom Season 2 is coming to an
end I think the last episode is coming
out on Monday and it is really good
I I can say this because I didn't write
it even drew said it though you know he
can't we were doing the we're doing with
the recording of it and he comes and he
says I got to tell you the ending of
this season is really good and then I
read it and it is really good so if you
aren't caught up catch up on it it's
exceptionally moving I really really
like it and and then we'll have to get
ready for season three God willing
that's our show in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
show have a good weekend
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you